quasiment à l'orge accueille maintenant
mesdames messieurs quelqu'un qui le 17
octobre avec son frère ivan va partir
pour la transat jacques vabre donc sur
son trimaran foncia qui s'appelait
primagaz avant vous l'avez tout reconnu
bien sûr c'est laurent mignon
or more you voilà alors la chance pour
nous c'est la totale
moi je suis bientôt le tournesol et le
bateau alors tout de suite en la matière
j'en profite de cadre au zoo est parti
parce que d'accord pendant qu'elle était
là je me suis tenu à carreau alonso avec
bon alors là on rogne ont donc la
transat jacques vabre du havre à
cartagena vrai alors c'est quoi le
circuit l'a dit nous là qu'on voit pas
ce qu'on connaît pas bien la géographie
mais alors on part 2
du havre oui incroyable oui jusque là
oui mais ensuite on va donc on va virer
la barbade
ouais on remonte tout les antilles
jusqu'à saint barthélémy et au nicaragua
vous prenez la coke si vous la prenez à
saint barthélemy oui enfin fo colombie
on vous livre la religion et le retour
chez eux en retour qu'ils appellent la
coque à cartagena et ensuite on va sur
carthagène le carthagène
voilà c'est parce que l'amiante ac en
fait partie ils vont direct et nous on
fait moins un petit peu plus rapide nous
font faire des petits dit oui un petit
peu pas vous partez le lendemain ou en
plus venant apporter le lendemain alors
déjà donc en 97 vous avez gagné cette
course 1 1 mais qui vont avec yvan et
cette année c'est yvan qu'est-ce-qui
peur pourquoi parce que c'est son
partenaire foncia et voilà c'est ciblé
et maintenant c'est lui qui va reprendre
le bateau jusqu'à la prochaine route du
rhum que vous allez faire vos moi je
suis en train de construire un catamaran
38 mali le fameux truc le gros projet là
voilà alors vous avez déclaré l'an
bourgnon pour moi faire de la télé c'est
aussi contraignant que brosse et la
coque de son bateau il faut le faire je
le fais mais qu'on me demande pas en
plus de sourires et là vous souriez et
là vous souriez c'est vrai qu'on est
avant tout notre passion c'est de
naviguer c'était un plaisir sur l'eau et
mais bon cela dit on change un petit peu
notre fusil d'épaulé parce qu'on
rencontre des gens formidables m'honore
mais vous avez dire j'étais au théâtre
pour les voir michel ouais c'est bien
qu'ils aient chuté avant c'était pas le
démon de midi c'est bien des monts mealy
première fois dans la loge juste après
j'ai vu michel complètement ouais il
tomba chez le racing fêtait ses seins et
faux vous allez le voir ça le démon de
midi
non mais vraiment en retard on se marre
du début à la fin
me laisserait que j'ai vu falher m'a plu
ou alors moi je vous connaissais pas
très bien
et donc j'ai appris beaucoup
j'ai lu votre vie et c'est vrai après
tout le monde voit la caunette j'imagine
que c'est une star énorme mais quand vos
parents étaient boulangers dans le jura
suisse et la chaux de fonds
jusque là rien de voilà et puis alors
quand même que j'ai toujours les
frontières
quand vous avez quatre ans vos parents
lisent le vagabond des mers du sud de
bertrand - tessier et là ils vendent la
boulangerie ça c'est énorme
ils vendent la boulangerie il achète un
voilier de 12 mètres
le père bourgnon fait un stage de trois
semaines aux glénan donc on veut pas
dire que j'ai vraiment et qu'est ce qui
fait de vous il traverse l'atlantique
c'est à dire c'est vrai un oui tout à
fait il était passionné en fait au
départ par laventure les voyages et
rencontres
ouais et connaissait absolument rien en
bateau et voilà on de stage de quinze
jours ils ont ils ont mis les voiles
direct on est partis en famille assez
incroyable ouais alors votre maire après
se retrouve enceinte de votre frère yvon
là il rentre à pornic qu'ils achètent un
café mais quand ils vont à 9 ans et vous
13 ans à tour du monde à la voile
voilà en de six mois en fait l'objectif
au départ c'est de voyager donc
finalement quand on arrive en polynésie
le moyen le plus court pour rentrer
c'est de faire le tour puis voilà quoi
donc on s'est baladé procès des parents
incroyable ça a aidé ou dont vous très
jeune quoi des vaches de présenter pieds
équipiers quand vous tenez votre place
sur le sur le bateau en fait ce que dit
votre père en tous les cas vous misiez
obligé oui alors vous avez passé sept
mois aux marquises d'aller à l'école en
planche à voile
il a eu une enfance qui devance ici le
voilà est alors en 86 âge raconte un peu
c'est quand même encore des gens qui
vous connaissent pas en 81 6 et 20 ans
et là vous faites l'atlantique en hobie
cat
bravo donc à savoir si un tout petit
bateau à l'aube et quadrillé ce que
c'est on a 20 ans on est plein d'énergie
et c'est vrai qu'on a envie de se faire
plaisir qu'on va on est en recherche de
à la recherche de sensations et c'est
vrai que lens était fait 22 jours de
piste noire sans prendre deux rebonds
tente
ouais et c'était un plaisir que
c'étaient les petits engins des engins
de plage à l'origine willoughby 4 fait
rien et dans les vagues
enfin c'était fascinant quand c'est fait
vraiment plaisir quand vous arrivez de
l'autre côté il y avait la route du rhum
qui arrive et tout le monde est
sceptique tout le monde y attend c'est
pas possible il est traversé
l'atlantique en hobie cat voix et
heureusement il est philippe poupon qui
venait de gagner la route du rhum et qui
lui
ici vous allez croiser ou non même pas
moi pas du tout mais il faut être au
fond du bar le faire quand même
euh ah oui non mais s'est défendu océans
les bureaux toute la journée pour
vouloir l'aurore pour vouloir remonter
leur faire il peut retrouver aussi la
bunge et la mer c'est fantastique c'est
beau c'est merveilleux mais c'est
vraiment dangereux en plus on va voir la
soutane à en avoir un deuxième enfant un
petit document il faut connaître un
petit peu le le métier après voilà c'est
pas mal la saison de weeds henry du seul
fait pas marrer le slash disons que la
solitude c'est pas on a les courses en
solitaire mais ce n'est pas l'objectif
d'être seul sur un bateau d'emile des
taux
vivement les courses en double mixte ce
sera beaucoup plus simple vers la fin
tellement de femmes dans notre métier
qui font pas long feu
c'est bien quand on voit florence
arthaud ça donne pas envie de partir en
mixte avec elle alors vous êtes un
maniaque
c'est bien connu vous êtes vous êtes un
dangereux ne devront pas trembler
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de ballons lui à
souffrir de vous jeter en signaler ici
non vous vous êtes un malade du
rationnement c'est à dire que voulait
déjà quand vous aviez fait votre
traversée là en hobie cat et 120
bouteilles d'eau dans les flotteurs si
vous êtes un maniaque du rangement par
exemple arracher les étiquettes de vaud
de vos vêtements
il coupe le mans il coupe en deux le
manche de sa brosse à dents pour ça pèse
moins lourd
bellegarde et pas de région ils jettent
à l'eau le tout ce qui pèse du poids
quoi c'est ça mais en fait l'objet
qu'ils ne s'inquiètent pas de femme que
l'on sache c'est pas le l'objectif c'est
véritable onde préparer le mieux
possible le bateau donc on fait
attention à chaque petit détail
justement pour qu'une fois parti il n'y
a pas de problème le manche de la brosse
à dents c'est beaucoup quand même assure
un petit catamaran de sport en fait le
moindre kilo est important on essaie de
d'être attentif à tout et alors pour
dormir dans commis a pas de femmes pour
pau pour dormir
bon on pratiquer l'auto hypnose c'est
comment quel rapport
donc si je comprends bien après l'amour
tu te mets sur le côté tu te retournes
disons que ça aide à s'endormir de faire
l'amour oui non ben l'auto hypnose
c'est des mots bien compliqué pour
expliquer des en fait la gestion du
sommeil on essaie de de réduire les
signes de sommeil dormira sur commande à
des moments donnés quand la météo nous
le permet ce qui fait que ben on est on
est le plus possible à la disposition du
bateau pour faire marcher le bateau
laurent merci en tous les cas moi je
vous connais mieux j'espère que nos amis
téléspectateurs aussi